we say to those that suggest that  Stephen Flynn new job just showboating  no because I think at the end of the day  it's about that responsibility that we  have to the public skein used tortoise  has shown a light on this politicians  have got a responsibility to act to make  sure that we make sure that we've  actually got the Best in Class  politicians people that we can have  faith in nobody's saying that there  aren't circumstances where MPS have come  in and they've had other interests you  know you've got people that have  operated in public services those that  have acted as doctors for example to  give one to one case where they can  carry on in doing that they need to make  sure that they keep their their skills  up but we need to make sure that the the  jobs that the politicians are doing is  primarily about that responsibility to  have to the concessions and they're not  Feathering the road Nest that's what  this is all about